bro
let me tell you something when i was
when i was a little kid i live by three
rules
don't beg nobody for nothing never fear
nobody
and number three don't ever do anything
that you're not gonna
if you say you're going through it do it
and when i look at the world right now
i'm like oh my god i don't even
understand like
i can't even have mother's day because
we can't even have a here or c
you feel me i'm like bro what time is
this it's crazy
i'm not feeling this it is what i am
feeling is all the money they're
throwing in the economy
let's let's just dump paper in here
bring the paper daddy i'm coming to
kitty
you feel me because think about it like
this if you got six dudes in a room
and five of them know how to get bread
and one of them is like
yeah like like well he gonna get stuck
for his bread immediately
feel me mm-hmm he don't know if you
don't know what you're doing you're
gonna get rocked
straight up bro how did you become so
[ __ ] crazy because i'm an animal
daddy i come from the streets of jersey
i was the oldest what was your childhood
like well my father was
my father was a garbage man and he
bought and sold anything
completely garbage exactly my father was
a garbage man
and then my mother worked in a bakery
you know what i'm saying and then i went
to a catholic school
why who knows i don't want to be no
catholic school i'd rather be on the
block busting knuckles
but hey you know what that's what they
did and then on top of that
my uncle my cousin toby's dad he was the
one who put me on you feel me when he
put you on to
like the game dog i was 10 years old
working in a hardware store so my father
was from puerto rico born in 1949
died when i was 18 years old my mother
your father died when you're 18.
yes so my mother her family came from
germany
excuse me let me let me holler at you
real quick
so peep this my mother's grandmother
you could smoke up in this piece it's
just vape oh it's just a vape no no
no no no no no i get it i get it so my
mother's
my mother's family right so my mother's
grandmother
her husband and her mother got killed
the same day in a concentration camp no
straight up and down feel me so they
came here in in jersey
in new york at ellis island boom so my
mother
was pregnant my mother was 16 years old
when i was born
my father was 19 years old feel me and
my great grandfather
who's my my grandmother's second husband
who brought here he was born in 1895
petrol strabis i was born in 1970 so
this dude's 75 years old
raising me cleaning pennies you feel me
growing um carrots cucumbers
and then in my father's family we got my
uncle my dad
these are like old school dudes you feel
me from puerto rico fighting roosters
over there they're doing [ __ ] fights
yeah look i got cocked right here look
pete
well let me see it put it closer to the
mic
yeah you feel me this is old school
all right yeah right here look at these
tabs what does that seem right there
it's a [ __ ] puerto rican flag chicken
right here paper hold up hold up paper
chaser you know why
i've been chasing paper since day i was
born this right here is self-made
careful of the tripod yeah tell me i
come from zero i've been yo
nobody ever gave me nothing the day my
father died left me
dead but that was a real ass dude he
straight up and down nobody [ __ ] with
him
real [ __ ] so my point is in life if you
want to get it
get it if you need welfare or some [ __ ]
like that you got to be out i can't [ __ ]
with you
straight up there's no way i can [ __ ]
with you
because if you about that loot you got
you got to leave box i get up at 4
o'clock in the morning
i'm already hitting dudes up yo what's
good where you at cause if you ain't
with me and you ain't gonna bang with me
i'm gonna bang with you i got bread i
got paper i got the whole nine come get
it
holler at me stick me for what i got
where you at
in the game of life if you ain't about
that grind if you ain't with that hustle
you're never gonna get it
that's why i told you i don't deal with
banks cause when i step to a bank
all right cool what you got here's my 10
here's my 10 31
boom i mean here's a 103. i got the
dough i got the credit boom
bro by the time i'm dealing with this
herb that works for the bank making 60
g's a year
draw it up he's making a g a week
i spend that in the barn two days if on
a bad week
can't freak with him so i'm gonna let
this herb rock
determine my destiny what are you
bugging i need to determine my own
destiny you gotta go get it
of course daddy that's what's up if i
can't do me
i don't need him cause i and then the
same thing with what i tell you when i
do loans
i how the hell am i gonna let an
appraiser who makes 400
an appraisal determine my deal
when
[Music]
do nothing illegal because in reality if
i gave you a million dollars not gonna
faze me at all
i do my sis straight i don't give nobody
i don't wash
pigs let pigs do them feel me i don't
need to deal with them pigs get fat hogs
get slapped
yeah you down who you down with with a
scarface but you feel me
i'm not with that here's here's how i am
i school you on the deal
i'm gonna look you right in your throat
daddy i suck your soul out where you at
feel me is either you with me you're
against me because i guarantee you
if you ain't gonna flip me you're stizzy
i'ma come get you cause i'm gonna see
who you're gonna sell it to
i'm gonna look up on public records what
you owe who you with i'm gonna get you
anyway
you feel me yes that's what it is cause
i don't need to grease a pig i don't
need nothing from nobody
i'm already paid i do this [ __ ] for fun
you want me to get crazy daddy let's get
there caught up in this piece
i know man okay it was the guy up on the
roof
the guy on the road i pay him rent that
peeked out with the blowers yeah we
could buy this [ __ ]
let's call it let's call him right now
at that dude i like that couch daddy
where you at aidan turn that up
there's a bluetooth channel on there but
why can't we smoke a stove up in this
piece
that's what i did let's get rid of these
there's a slider that
has a bluetooth logo on top it's a it's
one of the [ __ ] volume sliders but
you see it
you know i like your manual trying to
catch me slipping he's trying to see
what you got going on
day in my life he thinks you got
something on the back end going on
like it's too good to be true come on i
deal with real soldiers
no you could tell you're hustling for
toby i deal with my barbara d barber to
illustrate the country
i do yo my son is older than me my son
owns more real estate than i do how
would your son
28 years old i deal i deal with my wife
owns a real estate title excuse me she
owns a title company and i don't even
close there
because she's too legit to quit feel me
mm-hmm i got my other door to jesse got
two kids
here right no that way i'm sorry okay
left all right yes now screw it into the
table all right no you're good just just
like get like straight on with that mic
like just get like straight on like this
this way more but anyway i just wanted
to smoke cigarettes
man what else is good not much bro not
much i'm [ __ ]
i'm learning about i'm learning about
real estate with you bro let me tell you
have you ever played i want to learn
more about your childhood though i want
to i want to understand
what's going on in that head of yours
why how did you turn out this way bro
how how am i
you're [ __ ] wild man not really
you're a wild boy peep this
when you go to school college school job
they
train you how to serve the master you
feel me
yeah when you control your own destiny
you are the master
and ain't nobody gonna serve you you
understand there's no one like you
anymore bro everybody i rock with is
like me you get it
so i you you have to understand you got
to jump into the people
it's like this look i could teach you
everything you know but i'll never teach
you everything i know you get it
then at the same time if i deal with you
you and your man i'm a
i'm a rock on the way you think but i'm
never going to put you on my level
because if i put you on my level you
probably can't freak with it and then we
can't play
get it everything is a game what do you
mean i can't freak with it
it's like this look what i mean by that
let's pretend i'm trying to do whatever
i got to do with you
i'm going to look at you as like what
can i get from this dude
that i would even want to deal with
because if i can't if i can't conquer
what i'm looking for
i have no use for you get it so
if i put you in my field there's like a
million things i do
so if you don't know how to if i can't
give you the football and run with it
you're gonna fumble we're gonna lose
right so my point is
i gotta break you down and then pick you
up and understand what you got to offer
if you got something off from me i'ma
get it if you ain't got [ __ ] tall for me
i'ma pass you off and i'm gonna look at
your crew and i'ma look them all
i'm gonna try to suck everybody's soul
what can you get
what can i get from him what can i get
from him and how many other
[ __ ] you got in your click that
i can school
because if i can't get none from you you
ain't got no value to me
i